what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch
from toon sandwich art spirit
entertainment their wonder woman 1984
trailer spoof i think these guys always
knock it out of the park
right to the several of their videos in
the past if you haven't subscribed to
them do it
as soon as you can let's do it
my life this hasn't been what you
probably think
it has trevor rich it's a fighter
[Laughter]
a long long time ago i love the voice i
think i've
so many times yeah all the time i just
met this great guy
he holds my chair out for me takes my
orders gives me free breadsticks
are you talking about the waiter i love
him wanky badge
direct to cinema welcome to the future
minus three to four decades oh
no it's gonna be a great year life is
good
let me start going off
uh
i'm alive again how ugh
it's always these questions with you
diana how am i still alive after being
blown up in a plane
why haven't i aged doesn't this negate
my sacrifice in the first movie
jeez it's like you only want me around
if it makes sense
that doesn't include a bad damage
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh i see well just so you know she told
me she was in love a long long time ago
with some guy
and to be honest i don't think she ever
got over him so good luck
can you turn your square peg into the
round hole of her heart barbara
this is the guy from a long long time
ago okay so she loved you then i love
you now
who are you gonna pick i still love him
barbara
[Music]
[Music]
so that's why the suit was so much
cheaper than the bracelets
oh wonder woman
not just a trash can this is a trash can
yeah obviously
10 years of my life i spent sculpting
the reception
are you going to the trash can
[Music]
steve tell me the truth what could
happen if i subscribe to artsphere
entertainment
you would make these two people very
happy and grateful
and help them create more things hmm
that doesn't sound too bad you would
make me happy
if you loosen the left suit because i
think i'm joking
turning into
truly love thanos until you love
yourself
but i'm running out of time diana i'm
pushing 40 my skin's getting spottier my
legs are getting hairier i'm starting to
grow whiskers
no one wants to commit to me because i
don't think i'm a cheater
that was great that was delightful
there's so much energy today
so fun maybe they want to see that
version of them
that's hilarious that was truly
hilarious man
oh they knocked it out of the park on
that one i mean just the voice alone
and her accent and i feel like i don't
know if i'm correct about this
i feel like usually their trailer spoofs
are longer
like they they don't feel like the
length of a trailer but this felt like
the length of it of just
an extended trailer yeah exactly yeah so
never lost that rhythm
never lost that energy yeah it was less
like a
sequenced medley of longer sketches and
more yeah just like it had that punch
you know which i think is an interesting
flavor to add to the comedy of what
they're doing too because you know it
goes into the film style
parody yeah just the observational
parody
i loved uh the voice she does for uh gal
gadot
uh wonder woman barbara that's this yeah
it's like this foreign accent that's
really
trying to properly speak english yeah
yeah
exactly so funny that was really funny
they have these like little easter eggs
out that i would always notice like a
split second after they transitioned to
another
shot or something like that and she goes
up against the window and says oh lordy
on it
you know maxwell and i love the physical
parody gags that they do with all like
the bullets hitting her hand the plane
actually exploding on sea trevor oh that
reminds me of steve kramer watches
all the pictures of him around her of
him being either blown up or like yeah
the
family farm on fires like everything's
destroyed it always blows my mind to
know that's just two people who've
put this together it's two people and
that's why they're so late to
covering this one trailer that came out
forever
all this time just to make this video
exactly
yeah and animate and do the voiceovers
so
there's probably a version in their
heads that's having them go thank god
for the pandemic because it's made it a
lot easier to keep this a little more
relevant right now
yeah the next marvel trailer they'll
have a whole year to deal with that one
and i love that a lot next summer that
doesn't include a pandemic
well and the classic just tunes sandwich
pointing out all the sort of
general logic things you're thinking of
like doesn't my in return negate myself
the first movie these wings are pretty
impractical and they're mostly just for
looks
i mean i want them to cover all the dc
like dc phantom had so many amazing
trailers come out and they've got a
mattress
batman oh man that being could have been
huge every huge video
that would be the greatest art spear get
on it
and i know they've dealt with like
copyright problems in the past i think
they're superhero
showdown but the big the last big one
they did i think that was taken down
temporarily for like stupid
copyright stuff i'm like what they drew
this to
with the copyright on youtube there's no
no such thing as shenanigans here so i
saw that
obviously they took the the song the
blue mondays i was called
yeah um they took the song from the
wonder woman trailer
but they did it they like interpolated
yeah just enough to be like it's not a
new order
yeah it's different it's not it's not
even the remix
cinematic version the royalties
and i thought that sounded really good
and i felt like they really edited
really seamlessly well to the the rhythm
of that song and man they should be on
camera more they're both really
good-looking people
i know they should just mocap these and
then do a side-by-side
that's like they're i'm assuming they're
a couple yeah i mean you see these guys
and you like they they do all the
animation and the voiceover work
look at them they're both really good
looking i know you guys should do some
work on cameras
i feel like their animation has even
gotten a little bit sharper it's not
exactly 100 photo realistic but it's
pretty close
uh for the bringing the likeness of all
these people
these real individuals life in their
animation but then the way they're
blending their backgrounds up blurring
it up a little bit to
allow their characters to stand out to
pop out a little bit more
from the backgrounds i think are much
sharper than before
yeah they've grown a strong visual
earmark over time and
it makes it always makes me wonder like
are they taking images from these
trailers and of these actors and
rotoscoping them or yeah like drawing
them out but either way yeah they have
their own unique little
style and i love seeing also just those
images like even just the fireworks
scene like seeing how it's transposed
through the sort of animation style that
they have like that's also just part of
the fun for me oh boy
well guys come on get on it guys batman
make the batman one
schneider take one for the trailer
number two make sure you go for the
stutter cut do one of ezra miller what
are you doing
what's taking you so long come on you're
one division one where's your man
come on where's my car where's my free
content we're talking about content
it's my free content just kidding take
your time your time all right it's
quality appreciate it
all right guys well subscribe to
artsphere entertainment if you haven't
done so already
you can subscribe to the rejects click
that notification bell and last but not
least
considering this is wonder woman gotta
shout out a really
strong woman that is of course
maria hammond tough cookie
super ruthless honest lady it's had a
lot of
crazy life experiences i love getting to
chat with this woman
because she always has a great story to
tell
whether it's something that feels
uplifting or something that feels
engagingly tragic
it can be one of the two either way
she's always telling a great story
and she's always very honest she's not
afraid to tell me when she disagrees
with me on something we've
said or done but she's always supportive
and i'm happy to have someone like you
in my life maria because
you can't say that about most people i
think you and my girlfriend would get
along really well or you two would
really fight a lot it's going to be one
of the other
mariah you flip it around it's a double
you guys so there you go
perfect wonder woman right there you're
a strong woman maria and i'm happy to
know
a strong lady keep it up keep up the
strong the strongness
you're our lasso of truth
[Music]
you